madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
c'est la première vraie semaine de
vacances pour bon nombre de français en
nous verrons dans quelques minutes ce
que nous promet la météo pour cette
après midi et pour la journée de demain
marty deuxième nuit d'émeutes à
liverpool en angleterre 123 policier
blessé une cinquantaine de magasins
incendiés ce sont de jeunes noirs qui
sont descendus dans la rue la suite d'un
incident semble-t-il mineurs entre
policiers et immigrés entre la france et
le mexique c'est le grand froid la
compagnie française des pétroles vous le
savez a décidé d'interrompre ses achats
de pétrole au mexique et le mexique en
mesure de rétorsion à écarter les
compagnies françaises de tous les
projets de développement dans le pays
monsieur michel jobert le ministre
chargé du commerce extérieur en france
sera dans notre studio
dans quelques minutes la france sur le
chemin des 35 heures les négociations
ont repris ce matin au siège du patronat
nous y retrouverons laurence graff voilà
pour les titres je vous présente
maintenant notre invité il s'agit d'
alain durel à 19 ans il entre au
conservatoire de rouen pour apprendre le
piano l'histoire de la musique et
l'écriture musicale plus tard il
apprendra la percussion et la direction
d'orchestre à 25 ans il est assistant
digger markevich et enseignera même la
direction d'orchestre au fils du maître
à 28 ans professeur au conservatoire du
havre tout en demeurant producteur à
france musique
il s'intéresse aux méthodes actifs
d'enseignement musical organisme musique
dans la rue à aix et met en place un
inventaire national de la pratique
musicale amateur résultats de 1000
concerts en quinze jours dont 1000
simultané le jour j de la musique avec
tant de musiques diverses dans votre vie
vous ne craignez pas de devenir sourds
ah oui ça pourrait arriver mais
d'ailleurs il y a des
des musiciens professionnels qui ont des
problèmes d' écoute
il est bien connu que les stars du rock
perdre une bonne partie au bout de
quelques années de leurs facultés
auditives et c'est d'ailleurs un grand
problème qui nous préoccupe au festival
de la rochelle car dans le cas des états
généraux du bruit qui est une des
opérations du festival nous savons très
bien qu'à la limite il est vraiment
difficile d'organiser des concerts si
des gens qui travaillent dans une usine
de construction navale ou dans une ou
deux entreprises que nous connaissons
bien la rochelle
si ces personnes présentent des lésions
auditives car en fait à partir d'un
certain moment de surdité il y a des
choses dans la musique des finesses des
d une répartition des sceaux sur les
hauteurs que nous ne percevons pas et
c'est toujours un problème pour
apprécier des productions artistiques
venus pour le club a connu ça l'a pas
empêché de composer oui c'est vrai mais
beethoven il n'avait pas besoin la
limite d'écouter sa musique il
l'écrivait mais là nous nous adressons à
des auditeurs alors le bruit le bruit
dans la ville c'était l'un des thèmes de
ce festival est ce qu'on peut vraiment
parler de musique de festivals de
musique avec comme grande partie le
bruit oui car vous avez il y à la
musique contemporaine et très multiples
il y a tout de la musique dite
contemporaine c'est un mot bien bien
consacrer avec des compositeurs qui
écrivent des partitions qui sont joués
sur des plateaux dans des salles de
concert par les interprètes
mais depuis la musique concrète depuis
plus de trente-cinq ans dé beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de créateurs utilisent les
son quotidien et font de la musique sur
bandes magnétiques et diffuse cette
musique et la propose à des auditeurs
alors en fait les son quotidien c'est
quand même une chose que tout le public
potentiel du festival a en commun chez
vous sur la route pour aller travailler
dans le lieu de travail il y a des
problèmes ou au contraire des solutions
sur le l'environnement quotidien et je
crois que ce qui est intéressant pour
nous festival à partir du moment où en
liaison avec notre partenaire delà de la
rochelle qui est la maison de la culture
à partir du moment où nous essayons de
travailler vers un beaucoup plus grand
public que le public traditionnel de la
musique contemporaine
nous devons nous demander ce que les
gens qui travaillent à la rochelle
entendent ce qu'ils auraient envie
d'entendre
les nuisances sonores était un tout
petit peu atténuées et à partir de là
nous essayons de monter tout une
opération en liaison avec le monde de la
musique
cette opération s'appelle les états
généraux du bruit ben justement je vais
vous parler du monde de la musique pop
cracovie tête à côté de mousse et louis
dandrel qui est lui aussi un ancien
patron de france musique et qui
maintenant est directeur du monde de la
musique qui donc que soutient avec force
élections journal ce festival de la
rochelle on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler longtemps tout à l'heure par là
aussi des walkman parce que ça aussi
c'est un phénomène intéressant sur la
perception du bruit dans la ville c'est
la musique qui envahit tous là on va
parler aussi de la météo parce que je
vous le disais pour bon nombre de
français les vacances ont commencé ce
week end
alors on a une mauvaise nouvelle à vous
annoncer que vous avez vu que le temps
n'était pas très bon ben là gillot-pétré
coucher il a la grippe alors je vais
essayer de le remplacer dans la mesure
de mes modestes moyens en matière de
météo cet après midi d'après laurent
broomhead qui nous a passé un petit coup
de fil la france sera encore coupé en
deux au nord du pays
des nuages beaucoup de nuages et dans le
sud du pays du soleil alors il ya tout
de même un tout petit peu d'espoir selon
toujours leur andromède le temps devrait
progressivement s'améliorer dans les
jours qui viennent
l'été pourrait faire heures réellement
son apparition en france avant la fin de
la semaine les températures elles auront
tendance à grimper sérieusement long des
thermomètres liverpool a connu deux
nuits de violence pendant plusieurs
heures le quartier de toxteth qui est
habité en majorité par des immigrés
noirs des jamaïcains pour la plupart est
resté d'ailleurs entre les mains des
émeutiers la police n'est parvenu à
reprendre le contrôle de ce quartier que
vers 4h ce matin le bilan de ce week end
à liverpool est particulièrement lourd
123 policiers ont été blessés dont
certains très grièvement
et les dégâts sont très importants les
émeutes se sont déroulées samedi et
dimanche dans deux grands quartiers
populaires de londres et de liverpool
ici à sous sol près de londres
des bandes de jeunes gens aux crânes
rasés arbres en des croix gammées ont
fait des descentes dans ce faubourg
essentiellement peuplée d'immigrés
indiens et pakistanais
le sport favori de ces jeunes qui se
réclame de groupements néo nazis c'est
d'aller de temps en temps dans ces
quartiers pour 10 comme ils disent
casser du pâquis plusieurs centaines de
policiers ont affronté les charges
furieuse de ces jeunes racistes
le bilan 75 blessés long 60 policiers
une trentaine d'arrestations
adoptée dans la banlieue de liverpool
quartier à forte population noire
c'est plus d'une centaine de policiers
qui ont été blessés essentiellement par
les habitants du quartier les jeunes
chômeurs exaspérés par les tracasseries
policières
les syndicats et l'opposition
britannique rendent responsable
gouvernement de madame thatcher de ce
qui vient de se passer
ils dénoncent l'accroissement du chômage
et la politique économique néfaste du
gouvernement effectivement ces révoltes
dans cette banlieue de liverpool aussi
un peu le problème de toute
l'immigration qui est en jeu et
l'immigration jamaïcaine là justement
que l'on voit qui est très important en
grande bretagne et ce à des rapports
directs avec la musique finalement
l'immigration américaine c'est tout
phénomène du reggae qui est apparu un
viol vous savez lorsque nous nous avons
pour tâche de diffuser la musique est ce
qui se fait de nos jours dans le domaine
musical
il y a
il ne faut pas croire que nous arrivons
à toucher tous les publics
il y a quand même et ça c'est notre
travail de communication organisée la
communication entre des publics il y a
quand même une marge et parfois de
grands fossés entre un compositeur
traditionnel de musique contemporaine et
des groupes de personnes dont la musique
est l'expression quotidienne vivante et
personnelle et je crois que là il y a il
ya une grande matière à réflexion car
nous avons tous un petit peu l'habitude
et nous nous le faisons un peu
inconsciemment de vivre dans les sorte
de ghetto il y as est vrai sans aucun
jeu de mots d'ailleurs l'aigle et les
ghettos musicaux de la musique
contemporaine mais aussi tous ceux qui
s'expriment quotidiennement par la
musique c'est le cadet des jamaïcains
entre eux mais justement à ce que la
musique ça n'est pas de plus en plus
l'exutoire une certaine violence
on le voit peut-être dans le phénomène
du rock on le voit avec le reggae bob
marley c'est difficile de dire ça aussi
aussi nettement je crois que il y a
probablement un rapport entre la
situation d'un groupe social et sa
musique mais je ne pense pas que l'on
puisse donner une signification précise
à une manifestation musicale
je pense que si elle existe elle est
plus globale le phénomène du rock est un
phénomène qui traverse 20 ans de notre
notre histoire actuelle et il est vrai
qu'il y a une importante différence ne
serait ce d'ailleurs qu'au niveau des
décibels et la production des sons entre
un concert de rock un concert musique
contemporaine mais il ya aussi une
grande violence dans beaucoup de
manifestations de la musique dite
contemporaine savantes et sérieuse donc
la musique n'adoucit ray plus les moeurs
at elle jamais abouti
c'est juste nos risques beethoven avait
avait ce propos quand il quand il le
voulait produire une oeuvre
vous partagez le pire delà du rêve sur
seront donnés à vrai dire la question
qu'on peut se poser pour bob marley est
ce que bob marley est un homme politique
ou est-ce que c'est d'abord un musicien
et je crois qu'on ne peut pas dissocier
la jamaïque
absolument c'est à l'homme politique
absolue mais c'est un homme politique
musiciens c'est à dire une nouvelle
catégorie et quand on essaie de nous
faire croire que la musique est
apolitique
on se rend compte quand on tombe sur des
sur des situations comme celle de bob
marley comme ça ne va jamais y que c'est
dessus c'est une idée totalement fausse
la musique et politique franz liszt
avait une activité de politiques
d'hommes politiques et on retrouve ça
tout au long de l'histoire les mêmes de
la musique contemporaine dans la musique
contemporaine aujourd'hui ou dans l'acte
dans l'expression du bruit disant
d'emblée sous des formes sous des formes
tout à fait particulière mais quand vous
dites que par exemple le rock est
l'expression de la violence
je crois que c'est singulièrement liant
lt le problème sur une expression de
violence ou un exutoire une certaine
violence
oui mais faire de la moto faire de la
voiture aussi quand vous roulez à 180
dans votre puissante machine sur
l'autoroute et que je l'aurais je
doublerai c'est pareil je rigole on
continue avec vous et avec l'actualité
absolument
d'abord réduire la durée du travail sans
pénaliser les performances des
entreprises
la réunion qui s'est ouverte tout à
l'heure au siège du sel du cnpf
justement pour but d'étudier cette
possibilité
la première rencontre qui s'est tenue il
ya une dizaine de jours avait échoué
mais à la fin de la semaine dernière les
patrons avaient fait connaître leurs
propositions
alors les négociations de ce matin
réunissait l'ensemble des centrales
syndicales cgt cfdt fo cftc et cgc
face à une importante représentation du
cnpf conduite par yvon chotard
je vous rappelle les propositions
patronales elles portent sur la
réduction à 39 heures de la durée
hebdomadaire du travail
une cinquième semaine de congés des
discussions par branche et enfin la
création d'un stock d'heures
supplémentaires à la disposition des
chefs d'entreprise
laurence graff fait ce qu'elle veut elle
s'est engagée il ya début d'entente sur
trois grands points la réduction de la
durée du travail on cite le chiffre de
39 heures
la cinquième semaine
puis une négociations par branche il y a
aussi un début d'entente sur une marche
à suivre le 17 juillet on se rencontre
ont signé un protocole qui n'est pas
encore un accord mais qui lancent des
négociations par branches d'activité
septembre cette négociation par brand
justement commence et à la fin de cette
négociation on se retrouve on signe un
accord et à ce moment là on se tourne
vers le gouvernement et le parlement qui
font sauter les verrous qui s'opposent à
l'application de cet accord
si tout va bien donc une loi serait
votée dans le deuxième semestre 1982 il
ya toujours quand même des divergences
et syndicats insistent surtout sur deux
points la création d'emplois est un
droit de regard sur les heures
supplémentaires demandées par le
patronat mais dans l'ensemble on peut
dire que à la sortie cette réunion les
sourires étaient à l'optimisme les
français indifférents à l'entrée des
communistes dans le gouvernement un
sondage publié ce matin par le quotidien
de paris laisse apparaître que 33% des
personnes interrogées considèrent qu'il
s'agit d'une bonne chose à peu près
autant c'est à dire 32% pensent qu'il
s'agit d'une mauvaise chose pour 26% des
français en revanche l'entrée des
communistes au gouvernement n'a aucune
importance et puis dans une deuxième
question 34 % des gens se disent
inquiets de leur présence 21 rassurer là
encore les indifférents l'emportent avec
39% à propos des communistes laurent
laurent leroy dans l'humanité de ce
matin revient sur les causes de l'échec
du parti communiste aux dernières
élections
nous n'avons pas écrit-il pendant
longtemps fait ce qu'il convenait de
faire un nous que l'on peut comprendre
comme une autocritique personnalisés
roland leroy poursuit les erreurs nous
sommes un certain nombre à les avoir
commise une réponse en quelque sorte à
ce qu'ils accusaient le parti de rejeter
en bloc sur le passé sans désigner les
responsables comme dans le rapport de
georges marchais la semaine dernière au
comité central
et puis en politique française toujours
avec les objectifs définis par michel
rocard à saint nazaire dans le cadre de
ses fonctions de ministre du plan et de
l'aménagement du territoire françois
mitterrand at il dit a été élu sur
l'emploi mais comment imaginer que l'on
puisse réussir une politique dans ce
domaine une politique de conversion
industrielle sans écouter les
propositions de ceux qui sont concernés
au premier chef michel rocard qui ajoute
qu'il compte ouvrir très largement la
conseil
passion avec toutes les parties
concernées le rôle du ministre du plan
doit pour lui avant tout consisté à
organiser cette concertation politique
intérieure française un certain nombre
d'élections de ré élection avait lieu
aujourd'hui et dans les conseils
régionaux des élections des réélections
qui était bien sûr motivé par les
récentes élections législatives alors de
réélection tout d'abord monsieur andré
labarrère réélu président du conseil
régional d'aquitaine et monsieur pierre
joxe qui était réélu président du
conseil général de bourgogne deux
élections celle de monsieur laurent
fabius en haute-normandie monsieur
fabius succède à monsieur andré
bettencourt qui avait présenté mardi sa
démission de son poste de président et
quant à monsieur bernard stasi que vice
président de l'assemblée nationale et
député udf de la marne il a été élu ce
matin président du conseil régional
champagne ardenne peut être d'autres
élections réélection avant la fin de
cette édition on poursuit avec
l'étranger pour la première fois en
italie depuis l'enlèvement d'aldo moro
60,18 les brigades rouges ont exécuté un
de leurs otages
giuseppe thalasso un des cadres
dirigeants de la société montedison
enlevé le 20 mai dernier a été retrouvé
dans la nuit de la nuit dernière criblé
de balles à proximité d'une des usines
de la montedison près de venise un coup
de téléphone anonyme a revendiqué
l'exécution au nom des brigades rouges
ce geste croîtront savoir serait lié au
silence fait depuis plusieurs mois par
les médias autour des activités des
brigades rouges victor roman à rome pour
comprendre la raison pour laquelle les
brigades rouges ont finalement assassiné
le cadre de la montedison de venise
giuseppe taliercio il faut sans doute
revenir un peu en arrière et plus
précisément au mois de janvier de cette
année le 15 janvier les brigades rouges
libérer le juge giovanni d'ours
pourquoi et bien parce que certains
journaux italiens avaient accepté de
publier les proclamations de
l'organisation terroriste
c'était une condition essentielle posée
par les brigades rouges à la libération
du juge giovanni d'ours
or que s'est il passé dans le cas du
cadre de la montedison josep et alerte
chaud et bien aucun journal n'a accepté
de publier les revendications de
l'organisation terroriste
le silence a été maintenue évidemment
pour éviter de faire de la publicité en
faveur du terrorisme
mais c'est sans doute ce silence de la
presse qui a coûté la vie à giuseppe
talent et arthur évidemment tout cela
pose un problème de conscience terrible
aux journaux italiens et ce n'est pas
fini puisque les brigades rouges
détiennent encore dans ce qu'on appelle
les prisons du peuple trois autres
personnes un dirigeant démocrate
chrétien de naples un cadre d'alfa romeo
est le frère du célèbre terroriste
repenti patrizio pesci voilà en somme
les données du problème publier les
communiqués des brigades rouges cela
revient à leur faire de la publicité
mais refusait de publier ses communiqués
cela revient en somme a condamné à mort
toutes les personnes qui ont été
enlevées par les brigades rouges légère
détente en pologne après la visite
d'andreï gromyko le ministre soviétique
des affaires étrangères
la tension s'est nettement atténuée
entre moscou et varsovie les soviétiques
paraissent avoir entériné une situation
de fait qui est celle aujourd'hui de la
pologne un assouplissement de l'attitude
de moscou qui aurait un double sens lui
de faire de voir ce vide interlocuteur
est la tête de pont des intérêts
socialiste face à l'occident
moscou semble avoir compris que la bonne
image dont bénéficie la pologne à
l'ouest pourrait être effectivement
intelligemment utilisé en revanche la
mission de lord carrington qui est
arrivé ce matin à moscou paraît à peu
près certainement vouées à l'échec
il est à les transmettre au kremlin la
proposition européenne prise à
l'occasion du dernier sommet de
luxembourg de tenir une conférence
internationale sur l'afghanistan le
silence total de la presse soviétique
d'aujourd'hui est à cet égard
suffisamment éloquent en israël les
résultats officiels et définitifs des
élections législatives ont inversé les
premières tendances ainsi le parti de
menahem begin arrive finalement en tête
alors qu'on pensait le contraire
il dispose de 48 sièges c'est à dire un
de plus que les travaillistes de shimon
peres première conséquence il ne fait
plus de doute qu'il conduira à la
prochaine coalition
la seule incertitude de quelle majorité
il pourra disposer après le ralliement
des petits partis religieux
et puis parmi les ralliements possible
celui de l'ancien ministre de la défense
monsieur moshe dyan dernier titre de
l'étranger l'assassinât en iran du
gouverneur général de la province du
ghilan située dans le nord du pays
il a été abattu par des inconnus au
moment où il se rendait en voiture à son
bureau un de ses collaborateurs qui
l'accompagnait a été grièvement
vivement blessés par ailleurs toujours
en iran 21 une exécution est encore eu
lieu ce matin à la prison de téhéran
retour en france avec l'accident mortel
dont a été victime hier pascal géry mène
la vice championne du monde de voltige
aérienne à l'occasion d'un meeting
organisé près de metz la viande de la
championne française s'est écrasé au sol
sans qu'on en connaisse encore les
raisons elle n'a pas pu semble-t-il
redresser son appareil alors qu'elle
effectué un passage sur le dos au dessus
de l'aérodrome
son avion s'est écrasé dans un champ d a
pris feu immédiatement
pascal gemin elle s'était classée
deuxième au championnat du monde en
tchécoslovaquie en 1970 les français
n'ont pas particulièrement brillé à
l'occasion du championnat du monde des
scream qui ont pris fin hier à
clermont-ferrand
seule consolation la quatrième place au
fleuret de brigitte gaudin qui se
confirme comme un de nos plus sérieux
espoirs
la finale a été remportée par
l'allemande de l'ouest cornelia aniche
qui conserve ainsi son titre et qui se
serait certainement imposé si son pays
n'avaient pas boycotté les jeux
olympiques de moscou
la surprise pourtant de cette finale a
été constitué par la présence d'une
championne chinoise
cette jeune chinoise qui serre la main
de ses compatriotes est la grande
surprise de ces championnats du monde
d'escrimé qui ont lieu à clermont
ferrand elle s'appelle jugement elle a
23 ans et elle travaille à l'institut de
physique à ton cas en chine
hier soir elle est devenue la première
asiatique à se hisser au premier plan
mondial du fleuret armes qui jusque là
étaient réservées aux occidentaux et au
cela en quarts de finale elle bat la
russe lui la zone à puis en demi-finale
elle rencontre l'excellence française
brigitte gaudin que vous voyez ici à
gauche sur votre écran la française sera
battu 8 août à 3 parlant qui tire avec
beaucoup de concentration et surtout
accompagné d'une parfaite technique mais
tout cela ne sera pas suffisant pour
mettre en difficulté la tonine tenante
du titre mondial l'allemand de l'ouest
caniche qui rencontrent en finale
l'allemande remporte son deuxième titre
consécutif par lui touche à 4 et la
grande chinoise sa première médaille
d'argent
voilà pour l'actualité nous attendons
encore il ne devrait pas tarder
maintenant le ministre du commerce
extérieur monsieur michel jobert nous
évoquerons avec huile le problème des
rapports entre la france et le mexique
des rapports qui vous le savez n'ont
déjà pas mal parler se sont tendues ces
derniers jours allant même jusqu'à un
boycott pratiques dans les entreprises
françaises par le mexique monsieur
jaubert en ce moment même où thomas il
ya quelques minutes encore présider une
réunion consacrée à ce problème des
relations entre la france et le mexique
dès qu'il sera dans notre studio gassion
nous parlerons de ce rapport vous avez
une derrière nouvelle donne et ja oui
effectivement une dépêche qui nous
arrive à l'instant qui nous apprend
qu'un écoulement d'un mètre cube environ
d'effluents de rinçage a été constaté
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche lors
des opérations de rinçage d'appareils
dans une cellule du sous sol du bâtiment
haute activité de l' usine de
retraitement de la hague
voilà donc un mètre cube environ d'un
fluide affluent de rinçage qui s'est
écoulée on ignore pour l'instant quel
gravitaient ça nous arrange bien voilà
nous en reparlerons dans notre édition
de 20h rôle à la dure elle je vous
propose non pas de parler tout de suite
du festival de la rochelle car je viens
d'apprendre que monsieur michel jobert
et est arrivé dans notre studio alors il
est en compagnie de cas mérite et la
ville je pense qu'il va nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau d'une fuite sur cette
actualité que vous venez de suivre parce
qu'il y avait un sujet particulier qui
attirait votre intérêt il y en a
plusieurs mais curieusement
c'est plutôt je voudrais simplement pour
une information concernant la manière
dont peuvent se dérouler des festivals
ou des activités culturelles
c'est plutôt la question des 35 heures
qui me qui m'intéressait car comme pour
les musiciens
mais ça concerne les gens qui
travaillent dans le domaine culturel car
par exemple comme en réalisant nouveau
festival de la rochelle nous le
réalisons avec l'aide de tout le
personnel de la maison de la culture
c'est à dire environ 50 personnes
pendant la période du festival
et quelle que soit la pâle et le
caractère délirant ou non-stop de
certaines manifestations
de toute manière une entreprise
culturelle fonctionne comme une
entreprise normale et nous avons
également ce type de préoccupations
existe aussi pour nous je crois que
c'est important de le savoir c'est tout
ce que je voulais souligner et ça veut
dire que pour vous dans l'avenir sur mon
arrivée très rapidement 35 heures ça
poserait un problème très grave ou non
c'est que ce n'est pas forcément un
problème mais en tout cas nous devrons
forcément en tenir compte et cela veut
dire que les plans de travail doivent
être décidées en fonction de ça est ce
que ça vous encouragerez engager du
personnel supplémentaire alors
certainement d'ailleurs vous savez qu'il
ya mille emplois qui ont été créés pour
la culture et nous comptons bien en
profiter alou à la rochelle oui avant
tout à fait pris des mesures pour
revendiquer des personnels mais c'est
jamais à merci d'être venus aussi
rapidement dans notre studio je sais que
vous aviez une réunion ce matin qui
était notamment consacrée aux rapports
entre la france et le mexique alors ça
va pas très fort entre la france et le
mexique depuis quelques jours on leur
acheter du pétrole on l'aura n'achète
plus on devait faire le métro de mexico
construit des centrales nucléaires
installer des usines renault mexicaine
ne veulent plus nous voir tout ce qui se
passe exactement écouté il ne faudrait
pas confondre une discussion avec eux le
statut d'éternité et nous sommes dans le
domaine commercial chacun discute défend
ses positions et regarde quelles sont
les perspectives de l'avenir de
développement bilatéralement et puis
dans une projection plus grande en ce
qui concerne les pays de haute
technologie et des pays qui aspire à
avoir un développement bien organisés
alors c'est la situation de la france
par rapport au brésil
et réciproquement il y avait mon médecin
guinée et au mexique et réciproquement
alors il ya eu en effet quelques
discussions entre les sociétés
pétrolières qui ont contracté et c'est à
ce stade que l'on est aujourd'hui avec
une déclaration du gouvernement mexicain
qui fait passer cette affaire en effet
au stade gouvernementales et c'est à ce
stade où aujourd'hui nous essayons de
nous de nous rapprocher de nos
partenaires mexicains de façon à ce que
ce qui a été prévu ce qui a été tenté
pour l'avenir soit préservée de tourner
où qu'ils soient d'ordre politique ou
d'ordre commercial et je suis sûr que
nous y arriverons aisément vous dites
que ces gouvernements mexique acquis qui
met la barre un peu plus haut mais est
ce que la compagnie française des
pétroles n'a pas eu l'aval du
gouvernement français pour décider sa
suspension d'ashok pétrole au mexique un
coup de la question est de savoir quel
est le prix du pétrole
quelles sont les quantités livrées
qu'elles sont des quantités qui sont
proposés à la france alors sur ces trois
plans prix quantité qualité et bien il
est une discussion qui est ouverte
aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'au mois de
mai la pemex la société mexicaine avait
pensé qu'elle pouvait diminuer son
pétrole de 4 dollars le baril
le gouvernement mexicain ne l'a pas
suivi dans cette perspective et de bière
je crois que le président d'ap et mexes
a été échangé par conséquent c'était une
chose qui pouvait exister une baisse du
prix du pétrole mais il ya aussi les
accords à long terme il via le
développement de nos échanges avec le
mexique
et puis il ya développement de mexique
lui même et sur tous ces points nous
sommes très attentifs c'est la situation
aujourd'hui ça va dans la discussion qui
va souvent monsieur ministre est-ce que
la france sera éventuellement disposés à
payer le pétrole mexicain plus cher que
le pétrole des autres pays
simplement pour sauvegarder les autres
contrats comme le métro de mexico
je crois que nous les plus jeunes hommes
dans votre interrogation vous posez mal
7ce ce départ il s'agit pas de
sauvegarde et ceci en échange de cela il
s'agit de d'épouser son époque telle
qu'elle est c'est-à-dire qu autrefois il
y avait des sociétés internationales qui
faisait le marché du pétrole au prix de
ces sociétés internationales et
maintenant le pétrole et nationale c'est
à dire qu'il est dans la main des états
pour au moins 40% de la production et le
nexedi n'est pas dans l'opep d'ailleurs
souhaitent pouvoir lier ses ventes de
pétrole à son propre développement
économique et industriel
or c'est cette préoccupation là que nous
sommes prêts à aborder
vous souhaitez mais si cette
globalisation c'est à dire ne pas
s'arrêter uniquement prix du baril voire
plus vaste avec l'ensemble des efforts
n'est évidemment pas c'est une nécessité
du monde moderne alors si on sort des
nécessités du monde moderne on se
trouvent placés dans des situations
irréelles
l'outil plaçons points si nous
profitions que vous êtes là monsieur le
maire vous poser une autre question sur
un autre pays c'est celui de la
fourniture de réacteurs nucléaires à
l'irak
est-ce que vous avez une position
arrêtée sur la question puis écoutez je
crois que cette question relève du
ministre chargé des relations
extérieures et qu'il a parlé sur ce
sujet décision mais pour la vente ça va
c'est vous qui l'avez toujours su
renaître
tout le monde est concerné pour pour la
vente même vous vous voyez puisque vous
intéresser aux ventes françaises à
l'étranger
par conséquent je ne puis que répéter ce
qu'il a dit c'est que oui nous sommes
prêts à poursuivre cette coopération
dans la mesure des progrès que sa
finalité est exclusivement pacifiques
mais si dans le code de cette finalité
pacifique on forme les savants atomistes
qui sont susceptibles ensuite de
fabriquer des bombes parce qu'ils auront
les connaissances nécessaires à ce que
ça vous semble pas dangereux à tout est
dangereux dans la vie moderne bien
entendu mais je ne vois pas comme un
certain nombre de pays au monde et un
nombre croissant ne formeront pas des
équipes atomiste de savants atomistes à
la fois pour le civil est finalement
aussi pour le militaire pas la vie s'il
désire mais c'est leur affaire
derrière christian dans l'église
d'aujourd'hui oui le système c'est le
vous avez sans doute remarqué que le
dollar a une fois de plus battu son
record historique aujourd'hui la 5
france o samedi 7 il n'avait jamais été
si haut sur le commerce extérieur
l'affluence d'un dollar aussi cher est
évidente même écrasante
alors la question est simple qu'est ce
que vous comptez faire là cet hominidé
finances que vous devriez poser cette
question m'enfin comme il ya une grande
conjonction et solidarité
gouvernementale je peux vous répondre en
vous disant ceci on est très attentif à
ce que à l'effet de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt sur la tenue du dollar
et moi je prétends que la tenue l'art
est liée à la ferme nous venons par les
quais le prix du pétrole est aujourd'hui
les etats-unis ont valorisé suffisamment
leur production intérieure ils sont de
pétrole ils sont le premier pays de
producteurs de pétrole au monde où ils
étaient ils ont mis leur production un
peu en panne tout ces temps ci mais
maintenant le prix intérieurs américains
rattrape
la décision est prise depuis février le
prix mondial et à partir du moment où un
grand état les états unis à une
production pétrolière importante au prix
du marché ce qui n'était phase 7 $ autre
fois alors que le prix est de 30 entre
30 et 35
dès que cette opération ait fait
évidemment tous ceux qui sont attentifs
à l'économie savent que la monnaie
américaine est une monnaie qui est gage
et non plus sur des artifices mais sur
une production pétrolière importante
relayé d'ailleurs par une production
gazière et ceci fait forcément une
monnaie solide alors il n'y a pas que le
phénomène des taux d'intérêt les
réflexions que je vous fais la
conclusion que vous pouvez en tirer
c'est que je crois que la hausse du
dollar n'est pas un phénomène provisoire
ce phénomène durable manifestation
d'ailleurs que je me suis permis
d'annoncer dans le silence depuis 1973
maintenant on peut le dire à haute et
intelligible le voir j'essaie de le
faire construire à une question posée ce
michel jobert jock sur la musique ou
surtout jour eh oui oh non je crains que
sur la musique je crois que je suis très
incomplète
non mais peut-être dans le domaine des
aides du commerce extérieur mais je
crains que les préoccupations générales
leurs statistiques de vos préoccupations
ne soit pas tellement liés à des
phénomènes des changes dans le domaine
par exemple de la musique contemporaine
cela dit nous nous constatons dans un
festival comme la rochelle et où
finalement sont présentés une quinzaine
de pays
il y a au sens commercial du mot il y a
près de mille nuits d'hôtel qui sont
kiki qui sont fournies à la rochelle etc
mais est-ce que je ne sais pas si c'est
une question qui peut qui peut vous
concerner directement et surtout si
c'est un dossier qui existe est ce que
dans le domaine de la musique et en
particulier de la musique contemporaine
aussi bien ce qui concerne les
instruments que que les différents
échanges est ce qu'il y a un département
au commerce extérieur ou l'a7
cette question n'est pas une quantité
négligeable je veux dire du point de vue
du commerce m'écoutais je pourrais vous
répondre à mon propre dans ma propre
équipe il ya des gens qui intéresse
beaucoup
ce lac par conséquent vous pourrez
toujours vous adressez vous aurez le
meilleur accueil et que le ministre lui
même vous écoutera très volontiers et
vous avez raison d'évoquer cette
question
je prends un exemple entre le québec et
la france par une caisse qui a fait le
plus la politique bien entendu vive le
québec libre du général de gaulle
oui mais la chanson canadienne conquis
la france et je crois car elle a fait
beaucoup pour révéler le québec à la
france
alors je ne considère pas ça comme
quantité négligeable du tout alors on me
dira il s'agit pas des instruments de
musique
mais il s'agit de l'ensemble la
musicalité et de l'invention de la
chanson et moi dans mes responsabilités
de commerce extérieur ce sont des
éléments que j'intègre de même que la
langue française est pour moi un moyen
de commerce extérieur et hommes rien
dans le plus large sens du terme quelque
chose que nous devons à la fois préservé
cultiver utilisé l'expansion du livre
une musique française aussi et quelque
chose ce nom ce pas dire que nous
voulons vendre mais que nous voulons
multiplier à l'extérieur entre les pays
ça se pense souvent en termes de ventes
et des changes le québec je reviens sur
ce que vous disiez est justement le bon
sujet concernant la rochelle et la
charente maritime
nous avons des relations extrêmement
privilégiés qui ont donné lieu l'an
passé à toute une opération de la maison
de la culture de la rochelle qui
s'appliquait back 80 mais québécois les
acadiens aussi reviendront l'année
prochaine et je hais et là nous le
faisons d'une manière tout à fait
systématique
beaucoup de québécois sont partis de la
provoc de la rochelle où étiez vous le
faites comme moi avec les élégances de
la pensée et pas simplement
l'application du commerce
absolument je veux revenir sur
l'application du commerçant pour vous
donner un chiffre
monsieur vers la bourse est en baisse à
paris aujourd'hui - 0,79 pour cent pour
le début de la séance d'aujourd'hui puis
une autre information à propos des
élections dans les conseils régionaux
monsieur rené dosière qui est membre du
parti socialiste a été élu ce matin
président du conseil régional de
picardie
une action intéressante parce que
monsieur dosière succède ainsi à
monsieur maillet qui fut le premier
président d'un conseil régional
appartenance au parti communiste
monsieur mallet avait été battu aux
élections législatives et donc il ne se
représentait pas cette présidence du
conseil régional vert merci vous pour
rester avec nous si vous voulez parler
musique et festival de la rochelle parce
que ce sera maintenant l'essentiel
ce journal d'antenne de midi françois je
vous étiez la semaine dernière au
festival de la rochelle or qu'est-ce qui
vous a frappé à bien d'avoir un homme
m'a frappé c'est un album vous rappelle
nick torchwood qui à 57 ans qui a quitté
agents le danemark pour venir
s'installer en france et qui est un fou
de son élan c'est un homme qui est venu
avec sa femme et ses enfants dans le
luberon et il a passé son temps à
écouter pendant un jour et une nuit
entière sans manger sans boire et sans
bouger parce que les vêtements font du
bruit des insectes naturellement sa
femme et ses enfants sont rentrés au
danemark où on pouvait faire du bruit
relu et manger à des heures régulières
et il restait tout seul avec des
appareils électroniques qui l'a bricolé
et avec ses bruits de la nature il fait
des espèces de deux symphonies de bruit
qui sont tout à fait extraordinaire
alors je voudrais vous présenter vous
montrer victor creed victor cnudde
danois transplanté en provence où il a
construit sa maison où il fait son vin
dessine le bruit et enregistre le
silence peintres graveurs photographes
c'est d'abord l'image qui l'a passionné
d'abord que je vais commencer à dessiner
le sont parce que je les ai écoutés
comme
quelle forme sa leçon
il faut le voir
après avoir cherché à peindre le son il
a étudié l'eau qui est à la fois l'urée
bruit puis il découvre la musique
ignorait du réel c'est leur vie de faire
une étude sur la [ __ ] la segal qui fait
d'intérêts de son il capte donc et
orchestre les maracas des cigales puis
avec des sonorités qui l'environnent ils
se mettent à créer des paysages musicaux
parallèle aux paysages qu'il peint au
film le coeur des cochons d'inde lui
sert de percussions les abeilles de
violon
la rivière de l'arc pour leur signal de
flûte deux premiers l'avaient acquis
manche la pomme on avait tout simplement
acheter des pommes ou y avait des airs
de dents et puis je voulais essayer s'il
pouvait enregistrer
c'est le bruit qui fait s'élevèrent et
mon matériel et des tracts à krabi tic
et ce moment là mais pas avec avec un
peu de patience et un peu de silence ses
sens ç'a marché et il ça fait un bruit
ressemblant à quoi un verre qui mange
une pomme le bruit qu en fait comme en
chine comme oui on entend le jus et
peut-être aussi que le ver se régale
il ya les bêtes dans les bois
kim a mentionné g
le jour
j'ai déjà découvert c'est un peu la nasa
a écouté pendant
tout un après-midi et tout et tuent tout
d'une nuit jusqu'au matin
et pendant la nuit le bruit de fond qui
en a par l'amplification fédé
complètement et disparus je l'entendais
plus j'étais tellement habitué j'ai
entendu par exemple de berre qui tirent
leurs corps dans les couloirs s'ils
pouvaient même pas rester dans la pièce
vous enregistrer même les frottements
des vêtements saisis bruit pour que et
si c'est qu'il y avait un moustique qui
nous dira qui m'a beaucoup gêné qui
était dans la pièce ou une souris qui
passe et qui fait céder tonnerre vous
êtes fabriquer un studio avec du
matériel de récupération ont par leur
que vous avez trouvé dans une poubelle
des magnétophones qu'on vous a donné ça
doit quand même vous posez des tas de
problèmes
salut
côté très fertile aussi parce que
j'étais obligé de commencer à étudier
l'électronique pour pouvoir
reconnaissant seulement à la longue ça
marche
avant ces civils qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez pour pouvoir poursuivre vos
recherches à la fois musicale et
picturale de
oui
certains des grès des silences qui est
plus en plus difficiles à obtenir
même à la campagne bien mieux donc on
peut se poser
finalement ce genre de création c'est de
l'anti musique c'est l'anti création par
excellence c'est l'utilisation des
bruits qui existent pour en faire autre
chose de les mettre bout à bout
oui mais en fait vous savez lorsque et
on l'a constaté ces derniers jours à la
rochelle
lorsque le public de la rochelle vient
au théâtre des jacobins
écoutez les bandes magnétiques de claix
victor les gens entendent de la musique
est ce que viennent de dire connu des
très intéressant c'est que ian e une
photographie sonore d'un phénomène
d'érosion de la terre et je dois dire
que c'est complètement sa bulle eux
quand on a une bonne installation d
coûte
c'est un phénomène complètement est
ordinaire et qui donc devient un
phénomène musical car il est fait par un
artiste par un compositeur mais là il
fait partie ce qui me correspond au cas
des canons de l'artiste ou du musicien
tel qu'on le conçoit en france c'est pas
au conservatoire je suppose que on va
aller à prendre de jeunes élèves même
s'ils ont leur premier prix comment on
fait la musique comme cela mais il
faudrait pas en reste une
le portrait de culbuteurs zircon donc
quand on le voit physiquement on a
l'impression un peu que ca entre
guillemets à baba cool un écolo attardé
etc c'est pas ça du tout s'éteint enfin
pour moi qui l'ait vu travailler je
connais assez bien ses heures c'est un
vrai compositeur plasticien saisir là
encore une espèce qui n'existe pas et je
crois que il y a dans son travail une
sorte de rigueur poétique qu'on trouve
rarement aujourd'hui dans tout ce qui
est expérimental si vous avez par
exemple des travaux qui peuvent se faire
à l'ircam où il ya une recherche très
grande d'un vocabulaire de quelque chose
de structuré et de fort vous savez de
l'autre côté une attitude qui est
intuitive en apparence et qui arrive à
une production qui est d'une
d'une précision et d'une rigueur que je
trouve absolument stupéfiante
et tout ça sans aucun moyen oui non sans
moyens non faut dire que c'est
normalement c'est du bon c'est du bout
cccd truc bricolé
il rajoute il prend des des micros de
cassettes
c'est à dire enfin des micros tout à
fait ordinaire et c'est lui-même qui
ajoute 2 dans des petites pièces des
trucs comme ça pour en faire des micro
qui marche
il faudrait qu'on lui trouve une maison
de disques une maison de production qui
lui donne les moyens de travailler comme
il a envie de le faire
et comme il ne peut pas le faire qu'on
lui donne une pièce insonorisée qu'on
lui donne maintenant peut-être que si on
y donne tout ça il perdra son europe et
crêpe rouge non vidéo c'est tout ce que
je sais sur du neuf
thomas d'une recherche qui avait été
fait dans le passé qui était celle sur
le cri des baleines par exemple a donné
lieu à disque d'ailleurs justement oui
elle avoue d'ailleurs transition
merveilleuse nous plongeons nous
plongeons dans l'eau puisque dans ces
états généraux du goût il y avait en
illustration un travail de base qui est
de faire l'inventaire de nos espaces
sonores quotidien il y avait l'étude de
trois milieux l'eau la terre et la ville
elle va durer ce n'est pas d'accord avec
louis dandrel voulu alors pour ce qui
concerne l'eau vous citer par exemple le
chant des baleines c'est sûr que pendant
très longtemps on a dit que c'était le
monde du silence des ions enfin que je
pense que reggie va en parler c'est pas
du tout ça c'est un monde qui est
formidablement habité et c'est le monde
de la nature c'est en un certain sens le
même travail que fait que de victor le
monde soudain ses vingt mille espèces
qui presque tout produisant un son un
rack le mot un crissement etc
c'est que c'est quand même très
intéressant je dire on on n'imagine pas
ça et michel rodde jeune fille à la
rochelle nous la langue des
vérifications mais ça va nous offrir
travailler jusqu aux etats-unis non il
est il a incendié et où il a travaillé
au groupe de musique expérimentale de
marseille puis il travaille actuellement
à san diego en californie là le
pacifique devant lui et en fait il là il
a beaucoup travaillé sur les phénomènes
acoustiques subaquatique doux
l'expérience à la rochelle du cancer
subaquatique en piscine d'où également
certain nombre d'ateliers qui là qu'il a
fait ou on a découvert des bruits là
aussi des bruits fantastique sous marin
et que que personne n'imagine évidemment
quand françois je devais assister à ce
concert au subaquatique
oui et puis bien leur jeune fille
justement c'est un personnage
complètement opposé à victor parce que
c'est un compositeur heureux
bronzé sportifs heureux voilà la
californie alors vous allez voir comment
il a organisé son concert subaquatique
d'ailleurs il ne faut pas qu'on lui
enlève toutes les paroles de la bouche
voici dans sa salle de concert un
compositeur humide
contrairement compositeur sec michel
raynal fille plonge ses auditeurs dans
une piscine immergés ou faisant la
planche car on m'entend sous l'eau par
les os du crâne et non par les tympans
d'abord il explique la chose aux
mélomanes subaquatique habillés ils vont
avoir cinq mètres carrés le dos à 30
degrés pour s'ébattre en maillot le noir
n'est pas de rigueur
ils se douchent plus plonge au milieu
des jeux de lumière et d'une ambiance
musicale préparatoire enfin une fois
dans l'eau au milieu de 25 haut-parleurs
immergé et d'autant de le projecteur il
écoute une demi-heure de symphonies
électronique où l'on peut imaginer les
marées les dauphins les vagues les fonds
de corail et les voiles déployées vers
les îles sous le vent
j'ai fait il ya trois semaines cancer
dans l'océan pacifique cep en soirée
c'était dans ma journée et
les auditeurs étaient pour une part
étaient des gens qui allaient tout
simplement la plage votre partie des
gens qui étaient venus spécialement pour
cette île avec quelquefois 170 personnes
qui nageait dans l'océan
qu'est ce qui vous a fait passer de
l'ordinateur à l'océan peut-être en
voyage chez je suis allé en californie
et quelques années et j'y suis retourné
à plusieurs reprises et finalement j'ai
décidé d'y résider et en californie du
sud toute la culture est orienté vers
l'océan non non seulement les surfeurs
dont on parle toujours et qui existent
mais aussi les scientifiques les plus
grands instituts océanographiques son
niveau les militaires aussi tout le
monde était tournée vers la mer est
orienté à la mer alors moi avec mon
travail de musique expérimentale je me
suis senti un petit peu séparé de cette
culture au départ et la manière de
renouer les liens avec la communauté a
été 7
cette orientation vers la mer et il
écoute
fête de la musique expérimentale we7 et
hyzaar synthétiseur ordinateur et
jusqu'à matin j'étais un peu frustré
parce que l'expérience était toujours de
mon routage été guère partagé
ralentissement de musique expérimentale
il ya plus d'expérience au moment de la
fabrication de musique en recomposition
depuis j'ai égoïste qui compositeur
grâce à ces instruments
et puis moment où ça passe comme un
salon surtout sur des chaises on voit
rien je passe bien alors j'ai voulu
faire une musique expérimentale et pas
uniquement expérimental afin que
l'expérience passe de l'autre côté de
votre côté d'eux
de la salle this et le bassin tout le
monde va expérimenter quelque chose avec
son corps avec ses oreilles avec mais je
crois aussi c'est une expérience sociale
je crois que d'aller tous ensemble on
sera je crois que les limites soient 150
par penser d'être 150 a volontairement
se baigner en même temps et être à
l'écouté est une situation qui
socialement et expérimental un de ces
jours vous allez nous faire entendre le
chant des fameux sirène et chant des
sirènes mais je ne sais pas encore
découvertes mais je crois que je vais
essayer d'en éduqués que j'ai un projet
de travail avec des chanteuses qui
utiliseront très spécial qui permet de
parler et de chantier sous l'eau et donc
en europe un cancer des cantatrices
sous marine
ici-bas kotick
à
on
ces zones de blair et de leur large et
avec sa caméra très bon plongeur je suis
quand même certains cas une bonne partie
des téléspectateurs qui viennent de
regarder deux sujets qui vient de voir
cette musique soul ou et qu'ils me sont
complètement fous ces gens mais oui mais
justement ne pas vraiment tiens car il
faut pas oublier que en fait ce qui est
important pour des gens qui ont envie de
s'exprimer par exemple dans la création
musicale
c'est aussi de trouver des moyens de
communication avec le public
or au festival de la rochelle il y a des
à la rochelle il ya des institutions qui
font de la création dans différents
domaines
le théâtre du silence avec brigitte
lefèvre la maison de la culture qui
accueille dix sept mille personnes
chaque mois avec son directeur bernard
minier et qui pratique aussi une
politique de création le festival de la
rochelle bien sûr et dans le domaine
musical il ya les concerts que je
décrivais tout à leur disons tout à fait
normaux concert musique contemporaine
mais je crois que notre rôle qui est
très qui donne et dans ce domaine je
crois que c'est important ces années là
c'est d'organiser la communication avec
le public
or a priori tout le monde a envie
d'aller au cinéma tout le monde n'a pas
envie d'aller un concert musique
contemporaine et à partir du moment où
le commando est un compositeur comme
michel re dolphy une heure nous lui
avons commandé une oeuvre musicale et
que cette oeuvre est présenté dans des
conditions radicalement différentes de
ceux dont on a l'habitude
il se produit à la fois un phénomène de
curiosité mais aussi un phénomène de
sensations différentes de la manière
dont on perçoit la musique qu'à vous
êtes par exemple vous êtes dans l'eau la
grave il à la gravité vous et vous
l'apercevez différemment certain sens
sont un peu aboli l'odorat par exemple
dont vous vous sentez le milieu qui vous
transmet leçons et vous le sentez sur
votre corps etc
et puis vous avez aussi ces images que
vous avez très très bien rendu
finalement qui dans les premières
minutes du concert on a vu tous ces
corps allongés puis ces gens qui sont
restés pendant 30 ou 45 minutes selon
les cas la tête la tête dans l'eau
percevant cesson sans aucune
perturbation extérieure
je veux dire que là il ya un phénomène
de perception non pas d'une curiosité
mais d'une oeuvre musicale qui nous
paraît très important et je hais je
crois que c'est dans ce domaine là que
nous devons essayer de travailler
juste alpes a ajouté une petite chose
c'est qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
très curieux sur le public sait que les
premiers instants on voyait des nageurs
effectuer des mouvements rapides comme
quand on est dans une piscine ont fait
la compétition en nageant l'âge et au
bout de un quart d'heure vingt minutes
les mouvements commencé à se ralentir et
la dernière partie du concert tout le
monde est dans une sorte d'état
précèdent opus on a faim oui dites vous
disait clairement une espèce de douceur
tout d'un coup les gens se accepté de se
toucher vous imaginez au concert si vous
voulez quelqu'un vous met la main sur
l'épaule vous sauter au plafond
l'allégeance front laisse toucher tout
ça devenait liquide mais je dois je
n'allais pas de créer de race de
mélomanes la race des musiciens des
mélomanes traditionnelle celle qui va de
rock indé près aussi un peu plus rien je
crois qu éviter les autres devaient pas
traduction il y avait il y avait on va
pas rouvrir toute l'histoire de la
musique
il y avait un milieu homogène un milieu
homogène de communication que ce soit à
l'intérieur d'une église que ce soit là
d'ailleurs d'une cour de la cour d'un
prince
aujourd'hui il ya incontestablement des
milieux hétérogènes et là-dessus essayer
de retrouver une communication musical à
travers la musique c'est
extraordinairement compliquée
l'avantagent dorée dolphy sais que c'est
pas volontariste il se trouve qu'il y à
une musique qui est en accord avec l'eau
et que la piscine
elle appartient à tout le monde nous
avons parlé la vue du bruit de la nature
et
de ce concert subaquatique decaux
aurions nous pu parler également à
propos du festival de la rochelle et
nous avons oublié là l'usiné va
peut-être mais on nous aurions pu dire
effectivement que festival de la
rochelle c'est la musique la danse le
cinéma le théâtre et aussi les arts
plastiques
mais à travers toutes ces matières tous
ces secteurs
nous essayons le plus possible de ne pas
nous confiner dans un public spécialisé
qui d'ailleurs n'a pas besoin de nous il
suffit de faire un programme et il vient
ce qui est important c'est la
communication avec ses 85 mille
personnes de la ville et les 500000
personnes du département et je crois que
c'est ce qui est le plus difficile
d'ailleurs pour le cinéma c'est un tout
petit peu plus facile et la
programmation ou pas c'est d'ailleurs
tout à fait exemplaire attire attire des
foules pour le théâtre nous avons
quelques difficultés d'argent qui nous
permet de maintenir le terme que nous
souhaitons mais dans le domaine des arts
plastiques et de la musique qui sont à
tort ou à raison considérés comme des
arts un peu spécialisés nous cherchons
absolument à ne plus faire des
expositions des concerts et nous avons
fait une haie une opération qui
s'appelle autoportrait récit avec deux
artistes plasticiennes nicole croisille
alter qui a je ne vais pas la décrire ce
serait trop long mais qui a donné des
résultats à peu près semblable aux
modifications que provoque le cancer
subaquatique dans le quartier de mireuil
elles sont allés travailler pendant six
mois cela a donné une exposition presque
comme les autres mais aussi avec un
travail qui a concerné complètement les
habitants alors qu'on sait très bien que
lorsqu'on fait une exposition d'arts
plastiques qui y vient et jeu on a vu ça
moi j'avais vu ça dans les festivals
précédents à la rochelle donc je crois
que ce qui est important c'est avant
tout on fait un programme
on essaie de s'enraciner dans la vie
locale puis pendant le festival avec
tous nos partenaires ce que j'ai cités
tout à l'heure nous essayons d'organiser
la communication je dois dire
qu'effectivement c'est un sacré problème
et votre question tout à l'heure était
juste en ce sens là il y a encore des
coupures
l'année dernière c'était le concerto
pour flipper se tenait à concert
subaquatique l'an prochain que ce qui me
nous il ya ces récents au lance terres
de fenêtre
oui il a l'air des gens pour connaître
portes qui claquent sa salle et j'étais
l'enfant
mais pas comme ça au cours de laquelle m
avec aspirateur me faire carrière
on s'était captivant mais c'est très
intéressant de voir ces gens qui sont
tellement contents de ce spectacle et de
le faire aux mains de le faire de
communiquer à travers les fenêtres avec
nos voisins avec les sons qu'ils ont
chez eux
celle qui normalement voisin le voisin
et qui normalement lent poison
alors pour la halle pour l'année
prochaine pour l'année prochaine nous ne
pouvons encore rien à régler mais ce que
je peux dire c'est que nous ferons deux
trois festivals car l'occasion
l'ouverture de la nouvelle maison de la
culture il ya un festival en mars un
festival de jazz en mer liaison
d'ailleurs avec une opération louisiane
et acadie et un autre festival cinéma
principalement fin juin début juillet
nous verrons cela l'an prochain alain
durel et louis danvoye le merci d'être
venu avec nous aujourd'hui à votre place
demain nous parlerons d'ailleurs
beaucoup de la médecine gens savent en
effet le professeur galletti prochain
journal 18h30 c'est la vie à 20 heures
la tradition de la soirée à demain 12h45
de l'après midi